sickness is the presence of symptoms
so this is good time to say what a
symptom is okay a symptom is what you
only can feel
only you can feel an upset stomach or a
sore throat or that sort of the lived
experience okay so the sign is something
that someone could measure and tell that
you're infected like
virus in your nasopharynx or
something else right signs and symptoms
and so in a vaccine trial they tell you
if you have any of these symptoms they
give you a paper with the exact symptoms
listed to make sure you're picking them
up right so for flu it'd probably be
fever sore throat cough
you call them and then they will do a
pcr and make sure you you've got flu and
not some other virus that makes similar
symptoms
and then
they would say are you a vaccine or
non-vaccine arm and count up all the
infections and see how the vaccine did
basically that's so fascinating because
um
the reporting so symptom is what you
feel yes and certainly the mind has a
ability to conjure up feelings oh yes
absolutely and so like culturally
you know maybe there was a time in our
culture where
it was uh looked down upon to to to feel
sick or something like that like toughen
up kind of thing yes and so then you
probably have
very few symptoms being reported
absolutely and then absolutely now is
like much more
um i don't know
perhaps you're much more likely to
report symptoms now it's fascinating
because then it changes oh it is
definitely a perception because for you
know your symptom may be nothing to me
or vice versa right so when you're doing
this it's a little bit of a imprecise
science because
and even it's a cultural thing in some
countries
something that would make us feel
horrible they wouldn't even bother
reporting no i didn't have any symptoms
so it's a little bit imprecise and it
clouds the results so if you can measure
things it's always better but you start
out with a symptom
and if you say if someone tells you this
virus 20 of the people
are
asymptomatic they don't report symptoms
that number is probably not as a
constant it depends where you did the
study
it could be different in china versus
south america europe etc yeah
you